The origins of Mardi Gras are rooted in ancient spring festivals and raucous Roman celebrations.
By the 5th century, Christian Church leaders realized...
...their new converts weren't about to give up their pagan holidays.
In medieval times, the celebrations became known as Carnival,...
...a celebration of merriment that preceded Lent.
Lent being the Catholic 40-day period of fast...
...beginning on Ash Wednesday and ending on Easter Sunday.
At that time, no animal meat could be consumed during Lent.
So on Shrove Tuesday, the day before Lent,...
...European Christians would eat all the remaining meat, eggs, milk and cheese in their homes.
In France, this was called Mardi Gras: Fat Tuesday.
As the influence of the Catholic church spread, so did the pre-Lenten festivities.
By the end of the 16th century,...
...Mardi Gras was officially penciled in to the calendar throughout Europe.
Europeans who explored the New World brought among other things, the Carnival holiday.
Over time, Montreal, Rio de Janeiro,...
...and most famously, New Orleans became new Carnival capitals.